[Music]
in hacked scammer news Hasker massive
scammer submitted by David's uh Oh Davis
son Davis sir nice aunt in cream I saw
David saw baby baby just so why he's a
grey hat hacker fed up with fake IRS
scammers gets revenge in the best way I
want a hat hacker I want to be a purple
hat hacker the fanboy one the one that
just had shot LA
you know what purple hat hackers do they
come in they break into your page oh
yeah they make it over oh my god they're
like customer service like oh yeah like
you go into like an Instagram and then
like you're like you got ugly pictures
let me change it up for you
I go into the website like always
let me beautify it that's kind of
adorable yeah I just made it up though
there's no such thing I want to be up
her so that's what I'm saying I want to
make I want to create that I want to be
a purple a purple could they're fab
pretty color yeah because I mean come on
like black white grey pretty dull colors
oh those of you that don't know what
grant means it's a hacker that doesn't
have any malicious intent but they do
tend to break some laws or rules in
order to accomplish or they're trying to
greater good yeah and a black hat is
obviously it was just bad bad all
hackers that are just doing things to be
malicious and the white hat hackers are
people are just follow the rules they
follow the rules but then they try to
exploit the weaknesses to show you hey
buy my product if I do that that makes
hella money yeah my oh dude up show of
scorpions no no again I'm Walter O'Brien
it I think I like whatever age news
teenager he happened to some government
[ __ ] and cops pretty much like beat down
his door shouldn't like raided his house
and he he's a [ __ ] genius a prodigy
at this she just hit his 1-billion like
he's a billionaire now we're gonna show
out of him which is scorpion and your
friend dated dis person mmm he's a
really nice guy like he's cool friend
megive really go ahead yeah so that's
what he did he found that he's like if
you don't charge me I'll tell you how I
got in basically how he got off the hook
and then he makes millions he wasn't
like see I
I want to do that I want to steal from
somebody be like if you don't take me to
jail teach you how I stole it a lot of
people do they make times I think faced
with all for two million or so like a
good amount of money for people like
that in their terms of servicing anyone
finds my way in Google's who will pay
you to show us how that's smart
yeah so there's this security engineer
and redditor and his name is yes it was
data mined that's like his username and
though recently there have been a lot of
scammers posing as the IRS saying that
hate them yeah like they'll call you and
say hey you owe this much money to the
IRS if you don't pay us now we're going
to arrest you or deport you or and like
just garnish your Weiner
I remember they try to do that to an
officer well really to a police officer
yeah we talked about video what happened
he was just like laughing because
obviously it's like you're you're
calling of police officer saying you're
going to deport this man and all this
stuff and you're going to take of the
video you know guys I mean those an
Indian scammer yeah so the 2017 IRS
report states that since October 2013
there have been over 10,000 victims that
allegedly lost more than 54 million
dollars yes scammers I bet you they're
all like senior citizens to cut they
don't know anything I don't know so yes
it was data mind programs a script to
call these scammers and they were trying
to flood the phone line so he was trying
to call them 28 times a second so they
can't make other phone calls and then
try to scan more people so I'm going to
show you a two-minute video two minutes
yeah two minutes that's too long oh all
right
it's like what they do with websites
when they beat Austin they send a whole
shipment of whatever a new crash is yeah
it's like overload I can't [ __ ]
handle that yeah and so the video went
viral
there's actually um two videos because
he uploaded one that one went crazy
viral and then he uploaded a second one
so you combine both in the wild yeah how
do they know that 28 calls was going to
be the sweet spot and wrong with 27
let's attempt lunch like I see this [ __ ]
anybody good Matt we are well flooding
your phone line to the tree event
scamming additional death with scary
this will not stop until you stop
suffering extravagant health reviews
hello
it has been detected that you are a
Seraphim ah hello it has been declared
that you are a scammer because of this
we are now flooding your phone lines -
please leave a message after the beep oh
sorry
we are digitation wrong it'll be our
eyes okay hold on scam hello Nigeria
that you are wearing a service because
of this we are now flooding your phone
line to prevent you from having a dying
does not stop until you skies awesome
thank you what they change their wonted
detected that you are very busy days the
problem of the IRS Alcatel member at the
camera was Zoe wanting your phone lines
to prevent you from having additional
people this reward you but have all stop
who are your first of all I'm watching
your name hello scammers you are in the
aureus chance to make a decision didn't
think you H down your headset go home
and this will be over soon or continue
to have your lines clotted to prevent
you from having additional people this
will not stop until you stop came for
calling windows support your call is
important to level one of our agents
will help you shorten today yeah my
aureus chance to make a decision
please don't hanker for quality couple
to make a decision
plank alcoholics embark on pursuing come
on bowling my hope is so killing you
have the goriest a bucket you have the
same place down your handset go will be
over soon or continue
flooded should prevent you from scanning
additional people never comes down your
head double door wo Abu Darda there's
just a lot of cameras getting angry and
frustrated with you you know how they're
finding their number I'm not sure
exactly how like you look at the
lucidity
yeah cuz a lot of people Google like
certain phone numbers and then they'll
be reported as I you know ass camera
number I never pick up phone numbers
that I don't know I do so curious what
happen or they believe a yes man if
they're if it's important to leave a boy
voicemail always why are you so curious
about the person that's calling from
Tucson Arizona I don't know the [ __ ]
that's what I know who's in Tucson - I'm
coming for you I always get a phone call
at least once a day from some random
[ __ ] place so they never leave a
[ __ ] noise it's always like
Philadelphia Tucson you getting smart
now though because they'll put it then
like the area code that I'm originally
from and so I was like oh it's
interesting there's one that has my
exact phone number except it's off by
one number yeah waiting holiday in or
like some sort of hotel thing I mean I
never answer but I've been getting that
too and I'm like I don't know anyone
that has the same area code number is me
like come on stop it I don't talk to
anyone that has the same area I wish I
didn't have to work because this will be
much of this one thing to do
where like my time and effort is spent
on justice but like things like this
where it's like oh yeah yeah I'll come
meet you guys face-to-face I got a
million dollars and I can see them in
person
and we could get together as the rupee
team and kill them and fire rockets up
their buttholes yes dude I'll be so
don't like Batman and Iron Man but then
like we'll create whole entire companies
as a facade so we could lure these [ __ ]
that is on indefinite
Oh let me know if you ever do that I
mean you could join us Lumpkins
you could catch all the pervo alters all
the ladies and we can catch them Bart
could be the little kid that pretends
like he's a pet no no you know what
joins a pedophile committee okay because
he's not going to count as a little kid
but he could
share his love for children with the
pedophile community the pedophiles we're
gonna take it the wrong way I have an
idea you know those those men who send
me dick pics that have wives yes we set
up I'll be like I wanted me to hear and
then sentence why subpoena says hey you
want to find something out or like we
have a party scene some [ __ ] and she
shows up and then swim in the room
together it's like a Chris Hansen yeah
it will record all that [ __ ] oh yeah
nothing so fun of the hot chuck caterer
I'm down
you had them call cheaters yeah yeah
yeah that was pretty awesome
yes tight oh go back like the host got
beat up once he did all I miss you need
Joe Rogan from show like that yeah I
know what their [ __ ] ass yeah I think
the two worst people that are like the
[ __ ] that they do is one I hate scam
artists and swindlers and con artists
respondents they're [ __ ] spineless do
my [ __ ] money like robbed me like an
honorable man yeah me a [ __ ] money
okay that was very honorable people
don't [ __ ] sneak your hands into my
little pockets and [ __ ] pull it out
yeah they always take it old people -
yeah because they prey on the we only
there yeah oh man the same thing with
those [ __ ] cult leaders and all that
because they should be my followers not
theirs and then the other one is a
molesters don't like that anybody that
preys on the weak oh you're not an
honorable criminal you're a [ __ ] safe
town the strong put gun to my [ __ ]
face and say like gimme your $50 I
gladly give it to you because you know
how many people I could tell that story
to if you played I'll make it out yeah
give me a story time youtuber or an
experienced oh there's an experienced if
you get robbed I just stopped the guys
like hey listen dude I'll give you
everything but can I record it now blow
out your face I swear yeah dumb dumb and
he said yes say some racial slurs - yeah
there's make it better
yeah and pistol whip me so I get a big
[ __ ] lump in my head and then
everyone in the world feels sorry for me
I would just like photos in getting
excited alright sit one - who did you
tell him let and tell my Kyle you you
actually want me to let me pretend that
I'd beat you up like a nacho libre wait
that makes us the scammer now oh yes I
would scammers
see didn't once Vietnamese Gibson bother
you because it wasn't like that first
but it was you that popped it out yeah
okay fine yeah hiker he was being
interviewed and he said close the FTC
does all they can do but sadly it's not
enough no one else is helping these
victims I have been in the security
field for years and I'm so sick of these
scammers you know what though I don't
just go after the telemarketers either
we also record tech support scams and
turn them yeah that's really cool the
thing is like most of these scam crews
they're like dirt [ __ ] poor people
that are like I can't even have 20 cents
a day to feed my freakin eight kids and
all that stuff it probably worked for a
company that makes the company I didn't
know yeah all right it was like a
scamming company and they were all they
have the whole head set thing and
everybody got arrested inside they
probably don't know what they're doing
what if they don't even know they're
working for a scandal I work for
mortgage company not knowing that it was
a shady ass shady telemarketing mortgage
company I don't know [ __ ] about business
in real estate I was like 18 or 19 years
old calling in these people I thought I
was just selling homes and and in in
race I didn't know I was doing like
predatory loans these guys I didn't know
though until I was like hey wait a
minute this is this feels weird
during weren't the videos a longer
version of it the Indian guy or the the
scammer says yeah I'm a scammer and I'm
proud of it [ __ ] you
oh yeah I knew oh yeah Dana gain any
sympathy learn this hacker he says that
you know reddit in the YouTube community
is just been getting a ton of support
everyone was like [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] those scammers and so people are
asking if you can publish the source
code so then other people can do the
same but he's like uh you know they
might use it for malicious intent yeah
they can or like they're asking or is
there some way we can submit phone
numbers of other scammers so then you
can add it to the whole list something
it was like no cuz you might do it to
somebody yeah you might do it to someone
you don't like I like this guy man you
smart and you honorable bro let's be
friends
look at those good things hope you guys
enjoyed that episode if you guys have
any juicy little gussev details and you
guys want to submit it well guess what
you
ten cruise on over to the description
box below click on the link submit the
story and hopefully we will pick it and
talk about it from our videos click
right over here